[Musique]
autopsy durable et tu leur as beaucoup
de moi je les valeurs de notre art
s'empire parler nos jeux j'ai la rage
rappelle toi de nous à leur âge à nos
textes foudroyé elec
sache que le pop up renaître de ses
cendres on ne laissera pas une bande de
petit con le dessin qui parle de fès
depuis le 2 janvier à décembre il tire
complètement à côté pendant que nous on
fait des cercles et l arrêt thèmes plus
de dire que l'europe ce thème-là vingrau
es tu sais ce qui t'est mia van staden
que tu dises que le rap c'était mieux
avant on met la [ __ ] au tournant y
coach k qui mène la vie que je veux pas
dire faites pas si vous faites pas ça tu
auras comme dirait des messages de
prévention de l'état siègent pas les
courts met à celle que portait un bonnet
s'il fait froid
qu'est-ce que je m'en tape de techint
c'est moi j'étais jeune papa ton flow et
chiens des quotas je me suis endormi
trois fois moins d'eau pleine ville
le des grosses villas blel kadri dedans
tout est fatigué j'aime pas les
eurobéats car un franc et courtois qui
vincent la vérité vous méritez pas de
compter comme nous héritiers nous
irriter c'est ce que vous faites avec ce
même sincérité sincérité sa série des
ravinois pinebridge coupe des coupes à
coup de coude en toute sincérité me
tacle tablette un tantinet ne m'attaque
pas de tact jacadi a dit jacques tu m'as
contre-attaqué taxer le bruit de mon
armée nommée mon âme et ramène nous même
époque des bonhommes comme adoré
saroumane dur de moore moi je fais du
bivb 10 en dix ans
[Musique]
du genre oh oh oh regarde fiso fait du
rap qu'on leur a laissé il veut on
piétine et complet
on va sacrer and arts de la rue qui
termine dans une chicha parle de chappe
les chiites
de fait ces deux jours sans et cet amour
font les durs font les femmes et je les
paie sans effort un beelen dans le décor
nabuchodonosor et combien d'entre eux
ont vraiment connu la rue dans le prince
de bel air où ils sont ils arrivés là
voitures à petit tous les cas ce casque
à sochaux tout démoli bien ça chaque de
répéter qu on est foutu les boules d'or
gros tu portes
ce ballet battu bolt sujet grandit
tellement c'était quoi la changerons et
ça fait quelque 8 km en un clic clac
vraiment peur
dimitri ça va pas ça va pas d'insulter
les mamans des gens comme ça non mais
c'est la musique musique ou pas musique
je m'en fiche
les moments ça se respecte non cela à
faire de la corde c'est à sa mère enfant
+ 12 heures hamad
vraiment je trouve ça drôle d'insulter
les gens qui respectent leur mère non
c'est pas ça c'est juste qu'on croit de
miles qui étaient respectés les mères
c'est très important
ouais c'est vrai je sais pas ce qui m'a
prise
dit comme ça c'est peut-être le truc
d'ailleurs sur lequel on est tous
d'accord
ouais inspecteurs et maman sait c'est
important
on en a cure et pourrait
ouais
chez à lui faut la respecter si elle en
bois chercher
son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]